let's get some practice understanding
variables and the negative numbers that
they might represent or the positive
numbers so we're told to order the
following expressions by their values
from least to greatest and they've given
us these three expressions Q minus n n
and n minus Q and then they plot n NQ on
the number line so just to get our
bearings let's see this three hash marks
to the left of zero is negative three so
each hash mark must we must be going
down by one so this must be negative one
negative two and then this is negative
three and then so as we go to the right
each hash mark must increase by one so
zero one two and then three and then
this just helps us get a little bit more
bearings but let's just think about each
of these expressions so this first one
is Q minus N and Q is to the right of n
on the number line we know that Q is
greater than n so if Q is greater than n
and you're subtracting n from Q it
actually doesn't matter if Q if they're
both negative or both positive ones
negative ones positive just the fact
just the fact that we know that one the
Q is greater than n that means that Q
minus n is going to be positive and if
you actually want to look at this
particular circumstance Q is positive
and is negative if you subtract a
negative you're going to essentially add
a positive so this is this value right
over here not only is it going to be
positive it's going to be a positive
value greater than Q and if we have to
compare it versus Q we would know that
it is greater than Q but they don't ask
us to do that now we have n n is a
negative value it's a negative number
and it's a negative number between
negative 1 and negative 2 it looks like
it's roughly I don't know it looks like
it's approximately negative 1.8 we don't
know for sure but if we just eyeball it
this this thing is is negative and it
looks like it's approximately negative
1.8
now what's n minus Q n minus Q so it's
going to be the negative of Q minus n so
n minus Q we have the smaller number and
from that we're subtracting we're
subtracting the larger number so this
thing right over here is going to be
negative so the largest of these Val
is definitely going to be Q minus n
which is going to be positive and then
we have to figure out which is going to
be more negative this n value or this n
minus Q value well let's think about it
a little bit we could just try to
approximate what Q is and if we look at
it Q looks like it's approximately this
looks like roughly 0.8 and this looks
like it's approximately we've already
said negative 1.8 so if we make those
assumptions right over here this thing
is going to be approximately
approximately negative 1.8 minus 0.8
which is equal to negative 2.6 so when
you look at it like this you clearly see
that this is going to be more negative
than this right over here so this is the
smallest this is the smallest and this
is the largest or the greatest I should
say maybe maybe let me call this the
least that might be a better the least
because sometimes when people say small
and large they're referring to to
absolute value but let's say this is the
least and this is this is the greatest
so if we wanted to order them we would
go n minus Q and then and if you're
doing this on the Khan Academy exercise
you can actually click on these and move
them around but if if we can't it will
be n minus Q which is the most negative
then you have n which is still negative
but not as negative this is roughly
negative 1.8 this is roughly negative
2.6 and then Q minus n which is going to
be roughly roughly positive 2.6 so this
is this is the greatest and so let's do
the next question let's do the next
question
order the Phillips order the following
expressions by their values from least
to greatest so once again kind of same
drill although here each hash mark looks
like it's a half because it takes two to
get to one so this is half this is
negative one half right over here and we
want to cut compare a minus B to a to a
minus 0.5 so all of them were either a
you can even think of this as a minuses
a-minus zero all right that's the same
thing as a so let's see in all of this
we have an A and we're subtracting
something we're here we're not
subtracted we're subtracting zero I
guess we're subtracting nothing here is
subtracting B and here you're
subtracting zero point five so in
general the more you subtract the more
that you subtract the more that the
smaller it's it's going to be so let's
see which in which of these cases am i
subtracting the most well here I'm
subtracting a positive number
here I'm subtracting zero here I am
subtracting a B is a negative number
here I am subtracting a negative number
B is negative this is clearly positive
so if you subtract a positive number
from the city if you're from a you're
going to get a lower value than if
you've tracked a negative number in fact
if you subtract a negative number you're
going to add to a you're going to get a
number greater than a so the least is
when you subtract the largest value so
if you are the greatest value so a minus
zero point five we're subtracting a
we're subtracting a positive number
there we're subtracting zero point five
followed by a or we're not subtracting
anything and then you have a minus B
this right over here is going to be the
greatest why is this well we know that B
is a negative number notice it's below
zero right over here so if B is a
negative number you subtract a negative
number you're actually gonna get a value
that is greater than a let me make it
very clear this value right over here is
going to be is going to be less than a
this value over here clearly equals a
and this value over here is actually
going to be greater than a so now we've
ordered it from least to greatest once
again if we were doing it on the Khan
Academy exercises we would have a little
tool where we could click and move these
around but this is the least followed by
this followed by that now another way
that you could do it just like we did in
the last example you could try to
estimate roughly what these values are B
looks like it's I don't know it's not
exactly it looks like it's about point
negative 0.2 so approximately negative
zero point two remember this is negative
half this is negative 0.5
a looks like it is approximately a
negative and a point
Oh point seven negative zero point seven
and so you can actually do it with the
with the actual with the actual values
if you like but you would get the same
get the same result